we're here at what has become known as
hostage square and it's just in front of
the place where the war cabinet meetings
have been taking place since the War
Began now families have also been
holding Sittin here families of those
held captive along with their supporters
and today we've seen many performances
you have The Pianist behind us we also
saw a ballet team earlier performing
every hour that's because one of those
held captive a child was a ballerina and
they are hoping that she'll be able to
come back and dance we also heard from a
friend of one of those held captive she
was standing here wanting to remind
people she said this isn't just a poster
that you're seeing she wants to remind
them of that person's Story how he was
helpful to those around him and she says
she hopes that when he's there in Gaza
that he'll be help helping those that
are also held captive and if we take a
walk just over here you'll also see a
table that's been laid out because why
while this deal is a welcome for the
families it's only 50 people that are
being brought back and the hope for the
families and it has always been the case
is that they want all of the hostages
back here all of those held captive they
want them brought back here safely and
they know that if this doesn't happen
soon they'll be adding pressure onto the
government now part of that deal Israel
says is that for every 10 more captives
that are released they'll also be able
to have one more day of rest by one
pause in the fighting and that can
continue for a few more days with the
plan that hopefully that will mean that
Hamas and Islamic Jihad will release all
of those held captive it's still not
clear the details exactly it's still not
clear the names that are on that list of
those that will be released and of
course families even though they're
welcoming this it will be a cause for
concern for them if their family members
don't make it on that list of 50
captives h